china has responded with anger to
allegations from the u.s
that it withheld information about the
origins of the covet 19 outbreak last
year
beijing said washington had caught
already gravely damaged international
reputation
i'm sorry cooperation on covet 19 and
was now pointing fingers at
other countries the comments come as the
u.s said it had
deep concerns about china's handling of
a who mission
investigating the origins of the
pandemic in the central city of buhaan
the who team is expected to present
their findings as early as this week
several members of the team said they
were happy with the access to
information
provided by china but others including
australian microbiologist dominic dyer
said china refused to give the raw data
on early covet cases
and that this could complicate efforts
to understand how the outbreak began
if you're really trying to go back to
the very beginning
to try and understand the sources in the
ideal world
you would go through it patient
vibration by patient
and that's what we call online listing
no obviously all of that stuff is
anonymous
uh you know you don't want the patient
names or anything but but you want the
details on
you know what were the questions asked
what were the responses
and what were the sort of analyses of
the data
and that's standard practice for an
outbreak investigation
in this situation the chinese gave us
the results
we would have liked i guess to have seen
the raw data
but that can still come now with aspects
of the who mission to china still
unclear the uncertainty over the origins
of the coronavirus
are compounded by a deliberate
disinformation campaign by china
it began almost as soon as the
coronavirus began to spread through
wuhan asia and the world a rumor here
a claim there a conspiracy theory touted
further afield and
reposted had the virus been imported to
china via frozen meat
had one of its adversaries unleashed a
bio weapon in wuhan
as the world was fighting the
coronavirus a new war was raging online
a campaign of disinformation
people traditionally think about russia
when they think about foreign
information operations
with kovid that really began to change
and we found that china played a central
role
with copic disinformation analysis of
millions of twitter interactions by the
international affairs group the atlantic
council with the associated press news
agency
shows the chinese government weaponized
social media for a propaganda war to
deflect
blame for the pandemic the chinese
government has an incredibly
well developed
disinformation apparatus the
investigation found china's apparatus of
disinformation normally used on its own
people
was aimed abroad chinese diplomats added
dozens and dozens of accounts to twitter
and facebook
even though those platforms are banned
in china
western countries for the first time
saw china engaging in this more what's
known as
russian-style tactics of throwing mud
and seeing what sticks
the mud throwing was often aimed at the
u.s where top officials pilloried china
for
the pandemic when the china virus
invaded our shores
i promised china fought back against
trump's talk of a china virus
if the united states truly respects
facts it should open the biological lab
at fort dietrich
the chinese foreign affairs ministry was
speaking and tweeting the prospect
the virus was created in a u.s military
lab and carried to wuhan during military
games in late 2019.
tweets amplified by thousands of
accounts around the world
in dozens of languages and tens of
millions of followers
you don't necessarily want people
abroad to believe you but you wanna
have people come away with the
impression that well the
truth simply cannot be known a says this
b says this c says this i don't like any
of them
so who knows and that to the chinese
government at least in the international
context
would be a win polling suggested as
early as last spring that up to a third
of people in a number of countries
already believed the coronavirus was
man-made
for its part the chinese foreign
ministry says its diplomats use
social media like other countries
diplomats
and is opposed to the creation and
spread
of false information
you